هذا تقرير له بصمة واسعة
منك سيذهب بعيدًا إلى
المغرب في الغرب ثم إلى
قلب آسيا الوسطى مع
كازاخستان وجميع النقاط بينهما بالطبع
وبغض النظر عن المكان الذي تقاضيه ،
فهناك مشكلة هناك وخاصة
بالنسبة  أكبر مصدري النفط في الشرق الأوسط
الذين يعتمدون بشكل كبير على
عائدات النفط للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، سأضع العراق
على رأس القائمة بالطبع المملكة
العربية السعودية هي نوع من نفس الموقف على
الرغم من أنهم يدفعون بالتنويع
وشيء واحد نعرف أنه عندما  لقد
شهدنا الوباء في أبريل / نيسان انخفاضًا في
الطلب على النفط بنحو 30 في المائة ، فقد
شهدنا تعافيًا إلى انخفاض بنسبة تسعة إلى
عشرة في المائة على سبيل المثال لعام 2020 بأكمله ، هذا هو
التوقع ولكن هذا لا يزال
عميقًا للغاية والتحديات التي لا نواجهها  أعرف
متى سيتعافى
، فلنستمع إلى الجهاديين أو
صندوق النقد الدولي الذي
يرأس التقرير ، إنها خلاصة
قصيرة ، سيعتمد استرداد النفط على
عوامل مختلفة ، أولها الطلب
كان الطلب يلعب دورًا مهمًا
، كما أن عدم اليقين بشأن
الانتعاش العالمي يؤثر على
التوقعات بشأن الطلب ، خاصة
أنه من المتوقع أن تنخفض التجارة بنسبة 12٪
عالميًا ، ولم يسمع بيكي بانخفاض بنسبة 12٪ في التجارة
كما تعلم أنه لا يمكنك
حتى الذهاب  بالعودة إلى
الأزمة المالية العالمية وتجد أن الميزة الوحيدة
لدول الخليج كانت قائمة هنا
هي مقدار الثروة السيادية التي تبلغ حوالي
2 تريليون دولار الآن والتي أشار إليها MF
منذ حوالي ستة أشهر والتي
تستنفد بسرعة ولكنها أصبحت في متناول اليد
الآن لأنه  عجز الميزانية
مرة أخرى بغض النظر عن المكان الذي تبحث فيه عن ثمانية إلى
عشرة في المائة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي ، لذا فهي مشكلة ولكن
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين لديهم تلك الحماية المالية ،
فإنها تحدث فرقًا كبيرًا
بالطبع ، نعم ، وبعض اللاعبين مثل دول الخليج
لديهم بالطبع احتياطيات  كما تقترح
ولكن ما هي المخاطر التي يتعرض لها من
لا يفعلون وما هي البلدان التي ننظر
إليها هنا ، نعم ، دعنا نسمي هذه البلدان
التي ليس لديها  أموال الأيام الممطرة ، إذا
كنت تريد الأموال الحادة التي يعرفها صندوق النقد الدولي
أنه من الصواب
التحدث عنها من الناحية السياسية ، لكنهم أشاروا إلى ذلك ،
سأضع إيران في تلك القائمة بالطبع
لأن لديها ضربة ثلاثية في
قضايا كوفاتش ، والعقوبات الأمريكية والانخفاض
في  أسعار النفط في لبنان لأن
أساطير الاحتجاجات مرة أخرى في الأزمة المالية صحيحة ،
لذا فهي أزمة سياسية
ومالية ولم تقدم
المحادثات مع صندوق النقد الدولي اعتبارًا من يوم الجمعة الماضي ،
كما حددت هنا
العراق وليبيا كدولتين فاشلتين ، بيكي
محق لأنهما  ليس لدينا
البنية التحتية داخل الحكومة
للتعامل مع هذا النوع من التحديات في الوقت
الحالي ، أسعار النفط منخفضة
والأنظمة الطبية متوترة ، لذلك دعونا نطرح
نوعًا من التحديات التسعة عشر
وفقًا لصندوق النقد
الدولي الذي يسمونه ضربة مزدوجة.
لأن لديك أسعار النفط تحت
الضغط وقد تواجه عمليات
إغلاق إضافية في الموجة الثانية
مما قد يؤدي إلى احتجاجات وهذا
حاد للغاية وشيء ما  g هذا ينذر
بالخطر انخفاض عائدات بيكي ، هذا
رقم استثنائي 270 مليار دولار
2020 مقابل 2019 وقد تفتح أوبك
الصنابير قليلاً هنا
وتعود مرة أخرى في بعض التخفيضات حتى نتمكن من رؤية
ضغط هبوطي هنا في الربع الرابع
نحن '  لم تتضح
بعد وأخيرًا ، هذا شيء لم أكن
أعرفه حتى نظرت إلى التقرير الذي يفيد بأن
خطط التحفيز في هذا الجزء من
العالم هي الأدنى بغض النظر عن المكان الذي
تنظر إليه أثناء الوباء ، لذا إذا كان لدينا
موجة ثانية ، فأنت  ليست واحدة من دول الخليج
ذات الثروة السيادية التي
ستواجهها مشكلة في إبقاء الأمور تحت
السيطرة وكل تلك البلدان التي
تحدثت عنها من قبل كانت لديها احتجاجات
قبل الجائحة وهذا هو الخطر
الذي حدده صندوق النقد الدولي
هنا اليوم باعتباره
التحدي الحقيقي للمضي قدمًا إذا كان لدينا
الموجة الثانية
[موسيقى]